local now police believe there may be
more victims of a pastor charged with
sex crimes thank you for joining us at
11 i'm brian loftis and i'm denise
valdez furman rangel ramos led a church
in las vegas for nearly two decades
before he was arrested for sex crimes
with minors arko mana is live tonight
with how the vegas based community is
responding
denise and brian metro detectives
arrested furman rangel ramos for
multiple warrants related to the crime
of lewdness with a minor we spoke with
local religious leaders and mental
health experts who say more needs to be
done to protect children and their
encouraging victims to speak up
it's truly alarming the religious
community in las vegas is shaken
52-year-old furman rangel ramos a local
pastor was arrested earlier this month
for multiple counts of lewdness with the
minor
rangel ramos was the presiding pastor at
centro cristiano bethel church for more
than 20 years his name stripped from the
sign but the letter is still visible we
tried speaking with church employees and
congregants but they only told us they
were aware of the situation and had no
other comments i do want to extend my
my prayers for for the family those
involved pastor kelsey west is with the
completely different congregation in las
vegas he says adults need to be present
with kids while at church yes you're
going to do your background checks but
you want to make sure children are not
being left alone you want to make sure
that you have policies in place metro
detectives believe juangel ramos may
have more victims who have not come
forward yet it's also important to point
out it's not clear if the inappropriate
behavior happened at rangel ramos church
they could be scared and fearful mental
health experts say in these situations
kids and teens might feel confused about
speaking up but they need to be reminded
that their voice matters them coming
forward so they can get the support and
help that they need but then the other
part of it is so that this does not
continue pastor west agrees i want to
encourage children to please say
something
now anyone who may have been a victim of
rondell ramos is urged to call metro's
sex crimes unit at 702-828-3421
or to remain anonymous they can call
crime stoppers at
but a woman 702-385-5555 answered the
door at his listed address told us she
had nothing to say tonight reporting
live eric omana 8 news now